okay I want to talk about some really
bad optics from a Hillary Clinton rally
Hillary Clinton spoke to a crowd in
kissimmee florida this is just south of
orlando florida she was supposed to be
talking about jobs but at the beginning
she talked about those affected by the
pulse nightclub shooting and this was
sort of awkward because the shooters dad
was on stage right behind Hillary
Clinton during the entire speech of
course the shooter Omar mateen the dad
behind Hillary Clinton here newsChannel
5 spoke to mateen and said what was in
your mind when Hillary Clinton was
talking about that horrible shooting in
orlando that your son perpetrated in his
response was quote Hillary Clinton is
good for United States versus Donald
Trump who has no solutions uh and also
going on to say I spoke a lot about that
and wish that my son joined the army and
fought Isis that would be much better as
of right now we have not heard from the
Clinton campaign about whether they were
aware of this how he got up on stage
etcetera mr. mateen was also seen can we
put that back up for a second louis
holding a sign which said Hillary
Clinton makes the biggest investment
since World War two good for national
security ex CIA chief Morrell quote
Hillary told the truth about Benghazi
gun control laws so this is one of the
most extensive signs usually the signs
you see are like uh you know I'm with
her I'm with her something like that so
very very extensive sign uh I have two
thoughts on this right-wingers are going
nuts right this has been the front page
on Drudge Report all morning what's
going on look at this the [ __ ] that the
shooters dad supports Hillary etcetera
etcetera number one how on earth did
this happen right the optics of this are
not good anybody could have predicted
that this picture these types of
pictures would have just been fodder for
the right-wingers at the same time this
is not a man who was a terrorist this
man's son committed a horrible terrorist
hate crime atrocious act but this man
didn't at the same time this is a man
who blamed gay
blamed the gay nightclub for the
shooting and said that there's no reason
to go out and shoot gays because God
will punish them so from a purely
political standpoint this is just not
good for the Hillary Clinton campaign if
people decide to look into that at all
yeah it's a it's probably just overall
bad optics no matter how you cut it
really but uh interesting that uh that
he's throwing his support behind Hillary
well is he gonna support Trump I suppose
not maybe Jill Stein I might my bottom
line on this is terrible optics for the
Hillary Clinton campaign and for a
campaign that manages every detail so
closely I'm genuinely curious how this
was even allowed to happen it's uh yeah
uh someone I really doubt that someone
thought it would be good optics uh it
might have just been an oversight I that
could happen even with all the people
involved in every detail you have to
manage probably pretty easy for
something like this to go unnoticed and
the funny thing are not funny but
predictable thing is yeah okay Breitbart
has the picture up Drudge Report has the
picture of Wow but what argument are
they actually making are they are they
arguing that because this guy was on
stage Hillary Clinton's policies in some
way will submit to what the son of this
man did that there's actually no logical
sequential path of any value or meaning
here it's just bad optics that's all
that's the they will try to say that
look Hillary will make us less safe
Hillary's week that's the message will
try to to convey but uh yeah it's just
some guy standing behind Hillary my
prediction is within 48 hours this
completely disappears and hopefully we
never hear about it again let's take a
break next I will speak to will Maura we
nee about black lives matter